[Music]
let me ask you something do you come
home from work just to sit on the couch
and watch TV or browse dank memes on
your iPad maybe a friend will text you
wanting to go out later and you respond
pretty exhausted just gonna take it easy
tonight as if you have anything better
to do I'm gonna go out on a limb and say
that the vast majority of people no
matter how successful they are have a
lazy day sometimes it's just a part of
life so I wouldn't beat yourself up too
much for having a sweatpants day every
once in a while we all have them being a
lazy person in general though like being
lazy as just a way of life is a whole
nother issue and one that seems
especially prevalent in young people
these days an interesting u.s. survey
back in 2013 involving 13,000
participants found that young people
aged 15 to 24 were one full point more
tired on a scale of one to 10 than
seniors aged 65 and up which is crazy
and it implies that old people like
actual old people seniors have more
energy throughout the day and are less
tired than today's youth what's going on
here are young people more tired because
that's just how humanity evolved or are
we doing this to ourselves I'd argue
that they're not actually tired they're
just lazy now there's not a ton of
scientific evidence to back this claim
up but it makes sense once you define
what laziness really is psychology today
says that a person is being lazy if he
is able to carry out some activity that
he ought to carry out but is disinclined
to do so because of the effort involved
instead he carries out the activity
perfunctorily or engages in some other
less strenuous or less boring activity
or remains idle in short he is being
lazy if his motivation to spare himself
effort Trump's his motivation to do the
right or expected thing let me repeat
that a person is being lazy if his
motivation to spare himself effort
Trump's his motivation to do the right
or expected thing so in essence laziness
can be chalked up to good old fashioned
discomfort avoidance if you're lazy it's
because you're too comfortable that
doesn't necessarily mean that you live a
lavish cozy and problem-free lifestyle
it just means you generally fill your
day with too many cheap pleasures you've
conditioned your brain to gravitate
towards dopamine dispensers like Netflix
in facebook instead of hard fulfilling
activities that improve your quality of
life the consequence of that is that
these good healthy activities that will
actually improve you as a person seem
repulsive to your brain because it won't
give it that cheap and temporary high
it's been conditioned to expect and to
fix it you need to gradually replace
these dopamine dispensing habits that
you've established with good healthy
activities doesn't have to be all at
once but that's the only way to do it
start getting used to doing hard ish
things like making yourself a good
breakfast in the morning making your bed
or reading five pages of a book before
you're allowed to check your email
implementing these kinds of activities
into your day is kind of uncomfortable
but that's exactly how you stop being
lazy by embracing discomfort and the
nice thing about habits is they're
easier to do than not to do once being
productive and healthy is actually
ingrained into your lifestyle
voila you're not a lazy person anymore
so no matter how you spin it
laziness isn't something that's
ingrained into your genetics it's
something that's easily correctable you
just have to put in the effort if you
liked this video hit that like button if
you like these videos in general and
like this kind of content hit that
subscribe button I have a Twitter and
Instagram and a Facebook and you can
reach all of those at better ideas TV so
give us a follow stay productive and
we'll see you in the next video